okay for people who are joining this
live stream
we are looking at language development
for language
and our topic today is trees and we just
had the joke
this is a mono thematic meeting and i
was saying but it has many branches
uh okay um you know what i have a big
a big computations running in the
background let me kill that off because
i think i'm
i think it's gotten as far as it's going
to realistically get
can you open this in the prototype build
oh okay well in that case i don't even
need to kill off with the thing i was
doing
the perfect in the spirit of the meeting
you might want to chop it down
what the thing i was doing oh yeah
i'm trying to i'm trying to solve a 100
year old problem which is being quite
recalcitrant
i appreciate the pun
okay
that's a lot of beeping in the
background there okay
um okay practical question who who is
working on trees who is the
uh is it go ahead now ian
why do i think that tony is working on
them
at some point um at some point
we thought tony would be a good person
but he had other projects to work on
okay what is he working on oh he's
working on the entity extension stuff
yes indeed yes faster framework exactly
yes
okay all right okay all right should i
look at the guide here
yes i think so uh so the main change
here is that
since the previous time we looked at it
we have changed to using the data
structure
uh three oh nice yes and these provides
a much faster capability
and also because users will have access
to the data structure itself they will
be do
they will be able to do things with the
compiler which are
it's stressing you sorry it is new not
trees
okay sandra on the livestream is asking
if we have any
uh arborologists in the um in the team
here
and i think the answer is that the the
really crazy answer is i think we do
have people working on things like that
but not
in this part of the company um
okay wait a minute trees knew
okay
by the way there was an application of
this that came up just yesterday in
machine learning uh
strategy meeting decision trees they
have a representation for decision trees
i told them to go talk to tony because i
was confused
so somebody should unhook that that's
jesse
in machine learning um sorry i think you
need to
update this file razer changed a few
things this morning
um
so how close i mean it's been a while
since i saw this design
so right so i think
the first thing we want to discuss with
you is the
uh overall functionality the syntax etc
you know this is [ __ ] i might say so
we've got a function called tree plot
we're we're playing a silly game here
where
you know no we're not going to do this
having yeah so
this is the sort of thing we want to
discuss because the the point is that
root 3's
rule 3 returns a data structure
and so like graph probably we want to do
something better with it
once we want to auto display it right
right
exactly up to some size probably yes
but the point of this meeting is not at
the actual visualization
it's it's more like the design of the
functionality itself okay so
the wrapper is what there's a tree
wrapper
that is what this actually returns is
that correct it's not
it's a data it's a structure yeah if you
remove the tree form you'll see a data
structure
well that's not right i mean i think we
should specialize it
right that's not right we're going this
should be tree just like its graph
the fact that graph internally one day
graph internally will probably have a
compiled data structure
do you understand what i'm saying and
and and so should this i mean this
should just be
tree of data structure i mean if you
want it just be the data structure fine
but the tree thing would display as a
tree
right right and if you wanted to you
know it might have an accessor
that allows you to go get the raw data
structure if that's useful etc
i don't think that's right i mean right
we've been through this before
right that things that lie about what
they are
are a problem well that's what we do for
graph and graph is extremely successful
but don't lie about what it is graph is
its own
unique data structure and as a result it
doesn't play with a lot of things right
i understand that i mean it's it's this
thing here
right if i say what's the input form of
that
okay it's some weird thing here
personally i'd be much happier
if this just said graph of data
structure blah blah blah and maybe a
little bit of metadata
right right right but but data structure
is a specific
thing right yes i know it is but that's
not what this is making this is making a
tree
it's not making a data structure if you
want to make a a tree
data structure that's a different thing
and getting the tree data structure
from the tree object is a fine thing to
want to do
but the main thing is a tree object
right right
yes so we we we agree on that so we need
this wrapper
which in the past was called three
element and that's one of the things we
want to discuss with you today
okay
but yes so everything related to
visualization and the output
form is we know it's not ready
it's the main structure of all these
um extract paths etc that we need to
discuss
i i really like some of what we develop
you know the design we developed before
i mean i really kind of like the rules
tree tree rules
it seems a bit silly but i actually
think it's going to be very easy to
remember
indeed we use it a lot for construction
right okay oh nest tree that's
interesting that's the analog of nest
graph
exactly which i hope is going to have
its it's
uh let's not make the same mistake here
that we made with nest graph of having
lists
elements can be lists don't get that
confused
nest graph has some nasty bugs which
charles is right now fixing
to do with cases where the elements
themselves are lists
do you understand what i'm saying and
you understand what i'm saying
i i think i get where there could be a
problem there
right but so just avoid it
okay one issue here um
it's uh um
um is head
handling of heads uh
and i think we'll need some options to
determine whether you want
the heads compressed into nodes or
whether you want the head separately
followed
so yeah that's currently being handled
with the second argument
i see i don't and in what way
so there are named structures for what
you want to use as the data
oh i see that's nice that's makes sense
makes sense
the one that sort of heads goes to true
um so the default one is head
trees and you can just
have one argument
oh wow and this will need a ton of work
if you try very hard you're going to
break the visualization
yeah okay because that has to have a
vertex
and so what what's literally happening
here is that the root
of this tree its data is itself
a tree yeah
yeah i understand by the way in terms of
tree visualization just like text
structure has that way of visualizing
with the with the big over bars
we definitely want that as an option
here
yep and we also need to think about what
the future of tree form is
um which might be just being folded into
the stuff
okay so let's take a quick look but no
no tree form doesn't change anything
i mean maybe tree plot goes or
whatever it's called well tree form is
is a question
one is a formatting wrapper which i'm
well aware i'm well aware i'm just
saying that
it should use the same conventions and
probably the same code here
in other words what tree forms should do
is just call this tree object
this expression tree object even though
it's a wrapper right even though it
doesn't change its content
in terms of functionality is not a
rapper
i i know it's not a rapper i'm saying
tree form as a wrapper its format value
should be something related to
expression tree do you see what i'm
saying
it's format something that we had
discussed uh in the previous iteration
of the project and the main idea is to
avoid the confusion that we have in
extract of whether at least means a list
of
of positions or a single position which
is a deep
position
i understand it avoids the ambiguity but
at high cost
because i'm not sure that that cost is
worth it
i mean i think i think the question you
know the
the single level tree extractor seems
like a rare thing to want
but but okay let's take a look at what
we're doing here okay so
so here great you could extract
down to a certain a certain sub tree
okay tree cases of that tree
is showing what
the payloads are that match this this
this pattern right exactly right
but now
i see that pattern could itself be a
tree is that correct
if tree cases wanted to match subtrees
what would you do
i don't know and i don't think you could
just pattern match
to the tree well but but but
so why the previous so tree cases
when it went the tree element design
allowed you to have like a tree element
pattern
there in the second argument and would
try to match the tree
yeah i'm not sure how to do that with
this
and so tree cases tree position and tree
count
exclusively look at the data yeah that's
not that interesting entry select
looks yeah but we don't want that we
want something which can match up a sub
tree
i agree that's why we invented the
previous thing
so um
well what we need is a is a pattern that
can match our data structure
indeed but look you're obsessing about
the data structure here
right this is a particular data
structure the fact that we implement it
as a data structure is our business
right that you know what we want is a
pattern
yes there may be special code to match a
data structure pattern
but that's not the main points here
let's let's have a quick look through
what you've got here so one of the steps
backwards
is not being able to match subtrees
right yep
okay sandra is asking about functions
for siblings
which i believe we do have i hope we
have we had it before
yes for for extraction and referring to
them yeah
they're they're planned um it's
it's not implemented
okay so why is this tree insert not
using you see this is
you you you just lost your tree path
because
this why doesn't this use a tree path
right well that's saying it's inserting
the the
sorry what's equivalent to tree path of
two in the third argument where you have
two
that is just equivalent to saying tree
path of two
i understand that it's equivalent to
that but this is illustrating why you
don't want tree path
because look i mean tree path could be
have a role like key in associations
which is rarely used but not
used when you need to use it and also i
i have to believe that tree insert like
the
place part should have
and insert right insert has if i'm not
mistaken if i say abc
two arrow x that doesn't work
you're wrong what's up yeah i was going
to say you're wrong
insert delete i mean insert is like the
leak
right you give the position and then you
get the payload separately
but i think that would be a reasonable
syntax given the replace part story
i think that would be a nice syntax it
would be helpful to uh it's not
particularly profound but it's a helpful
syntax it seems to me
i would recommend that we support the
syntax but for trees
it feels like the right thing to insert
i mean so is there a tree replace part
yes and it isn't just replace part
correct it's the analog of tree insert
okay let's take a look at these some of
these
okay
so the the main idea of three element
was that it was very nested
which it may be useful for manipulations
but it gets very slow
well i don't understand i mean the it
the implementation
is is through data structures right the
question of the exposure is a different
story
so i mean right now with one of the
issues is the tagging of a tree
a tree head a a a tree node
right so an xml element there's you know
we understand that there's tags
associated with that element so how
would that work
in your in your representation here
you just have an expression at every
every node is just an expression correct
yep okay
and um so we're not identifying
i i'm very confused here the node is an
expression
and it's siblings and it's descendants
right
just like tree element is the data and
the subtrees right
this must be the same thing yep
essentially yes the data structure
contains
the payload and the list of children
right so why isn't it just three
elements i mean
you know don't tell me anything about
implementation because that's not you
know
conceptually i don't understand why it
isn't just three elements
because i'm saying if we had tree
elements then we could use that for
matching and so on
what that compiles into is a different
story
i'm making sense
um i think i understand what you mean
but but um
we want something that is able to
perform
fast enough guys guys do you need me to
do the software engineering it's not
very difficult
all you do is the outer tree element
turns the inside stuff into an opaque
tree object you know tree element which
has which has the data structure
when you go and use these functions they
compile the pieces
so that they operate on the data
structure right
we're not saying if you go in raw and
you start doing part extraction and so
on
it's perfectly reasonable for this to be
a raw object did you understand what i'm
saying
which has its own tree extractor
functions not
part extraction do you see what i'm
saying
i think so yep okay
so i mean because this is the as if it
was this
doesn't need to be this it's just as if
it was this
because this would give us you know
yeah i'm not sure we needs a little bit
more thought but to me that's that seems
like the right thing
yeah i think it needs a lot more thought
right because
you know once you compiled it right i
mean
is that tree element still there
no it's not right right see so
it's not still there but but but but it
i look the question is
what else you're saying it is what's
that not as simple as you're saying it
is
no but it's not what should determine
the desire but it's not that simple
right it shouldn't determine the design
that do everything yes okay so i mean
the main issue is
if what we want
okay at some point there is an
expression
i don't care what any of these things
are right the nest tree and
whatever it is right in the end there is
a thing i could type in to get this tree
what what is that thing right now i mean
this is making a tree
from rules but i want to know what do i
type in raw to just get a tree
if i want to specify the tree in its own
terms what do i type in
in its own what do you mean by that i
mean this is a constructor freeze right
i don't want a constructor i want the
actual i want to specify
step by step the actual tree
right i understand that to mean you
would need the tree element
fine then then then that's that's what
tree elements role is
it is the symbolically specified every
detail of how the tree looks
not a constructor for the tree from
other expressions
right and you can think of it as a
constructor itself just like rules tree
is a constructor
so the outer tree element is also a
constructor
i mean it's conceivable that we want an
outer wrapper called tree
that is outer wrapper an outer wrapper
on the outside
even of the tree element stuff i think
we had discussed that before
right i think that was the original
original design we had was an outer
wrapper of tree
and then its innards were all tree
elements but i think we decided we
didn't need the outer tree wrapper
it didn't need any separate metadata am
i right
right the last design we had was just
three elements nested
right so that may work and may not work
clearly if we had an outer tree
object then that outer tree object is
the thing that performs the data
structure level construction
that takes those tree element things
just like rules tree takes these things
and and packs them into a data structure
you see what i'm saying
right so if we had an outer tree thing
that's what it would do
now the issue is there are various
things that we need to be able to do
like for example
we would like to be able to match you
know as soon as we have any tree like
like for example
here's here's a tree i could make okay
let me make a tree
right there i'm going to just make a
tree
that says uh a blank goes
to b blank two
okay there we go now i have a pattern
tree
i want to be able to um uh
you know to take that patent tree and
match it with with tree cases right
do you want to look for substrates i
want to look for sub trees
and and that has to work you know that
that is a natural
thing that should work so any tree
construction
that involves patterns like this should
be able to be thought of as a pattern
and and you know uh tree cases and so on
should be able to
to to to extract with it does that make
sense
yes okay this is an idea
that does an existing graph and that's
that's a bit boring um
for example hold on hold on hold on let
me think about that for a second
actually it does exist in graph it is
graph rewriting
and that's what we have all of these
wolf and model physics project things
doing
it's quite non-trivial but we actually
have you know very good code for that
now
you see what i'm saying but it's quite
complicated in the graph case
the trees case is much easier
the graph case this is precisely what
you're doing
in the graph case is you know a match
for a graph for a pattern graph is
precisely
you know if you look at um look you know
in the theory that there's actually no
new idea
ever right i mean in in um
if you look for example
i'm pretty sure the end of this
basically shows okay so this is
oops this is precisely doing this
this is um
uh yeah i mean it's exactly this this
this problem there it is no patterns
there's the pattern there it is there's
the pattern
okay it's not done in a graph because we
don't have that capability
i'm just saying that this is what we are
implementing here
see what i'm saying right i understand
that the operation is certainly possible
thinking about the the design language
right right right so i mean this is a
graph rewrite okay
that those should have blanks on them
okay
and it has a module on the right-hand
side because it creates a variable
okay i'm just telling you this is pretty
non-trivial the scarf rewriting stuff
um and
yes here's why it's non-trivial okay
it's the whole story of multi-way
systems and in fact the story of quantum
mechanics as it turns out
um is the fact that there are many
different ways to do this graph
rewriting
right for any given for any given graph
i wasn't expecting to show this in this
meeting but for any given graph
right this is a graph rewriting process
okay
and there are many ways to do that
rewriting
you see um
actually that's a quartal graph so i
don't even know where the graph rewrite
yeah this is this is these are these are
look look at that graph there
those are the three rewrites that can be
done on that graph there
okay so that is not a problem that you
have in trees trees are unique rewrites
i think
yes they are right
unless if you're assuming you're
matching from the top
down
right right which i think is a good
assumption
but the whole point is it's very
important distinction they are unique
rewrites
as soon as we're doing graph rewrites
it's not unique at all and it's very
complicated i mean specifying
which of the graph rewrites to do is
even more complicated than specifying in
an expression
which you know when you look when you do
evaluation or recursion through an
expression
which thing to do which is itself very
complicated and we've never really
resolved how to do
so i think it's a very good assumption
that we go
you know that the tree tree matching is
from the top down
when it's nice and unique just like
expression matching is unique
you see what i'm saying
can i ask so would that pattern there
would that only match a tree with
exactly three um
no i think that's the question for tree
position right tree position
would match this it's just exactly the
same as the difference in replace and
slash dot for example
so i'm saying replace only matches the
whole enchilada
and replace and you know replace all
ghosts everywhere
are making sense and we'd want the same
thing with tree replace we want to do
the same kind of thing i think
again i haven't thought it through
completely but it's the same exact story
the general problem we always have in
trees is the distinction between the
subtree and the payload
of the root so we always have to specify
are you trying to match
the payload or are you trying to match
the whole i i understand and that's
exactly why we need tree element
because tree element clarifies that
and in this particular case this rules
tree has to have a rule for how it
turns itself every tree has to be
thought of
as if it was made from tree elements
right because every tree has to have
at each node it has to have the node
payload
and the subtrees am i making sense
yep and and you know
rules tree may construct something i i
don't know what the convention is for
what this means
right i'm assuming that the convention
is
this is the payload at that node
right right and that this is the subtree
elements
nick is pointing out how a tree rewrites
unique
um okay several people are pointing out
that i may be wrong about this
okay so hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on
um uh
well they're unique up to up to the the
canonical search order
right we have defined the canonical
search order for a play stall
which is top to bottom left to right at
each level
yes and so within that framework
that defines a unique consistent
search order for a tree
okay but but now right now and we had
that in the previous design
we can also have named edges here right
in other words or is it the case that
these are positional you know
in the previous design we had had the
idea that tree elements could either be
a list of tree elements or an
association of tree elements right
this is just a list of i understand that
but i'm saying it should also be able to
be an association of tree elements
now don't bleat about how data structure
doesn't support that because it needs to
did you understand what i'm saying
right that's the let's let's the next
time we review this i want to see the
previous design
because we seem to be going backwards
from that in a bunch of places here
i mean we do need to be able to have
named
edges here that's going to be important
in all sorts of kinds of trees
does that make sense yes
it's true that by changing to data
structure we have been limited in a
number so that's nonsense that's that's
the wrong way to think about it
data structure needs to be extended it's
not difficult to extend
it needs to be extended to handle
whatever you need to handle
right and it could be that that there's
a pure tree data structure and there's a
label tree data structure for example
which are different
and you get to choose between them
depending on what's actually in a
particular tree
and if a particular tree just like you
know if we i don't know whether we have
for graphs whether we have different
representations i don't even know where
we have different representations
for different kinds but we might have
you see what i'm saying
right so so here this should be able to
be an association
and again we should be able to match
against those things
now in terms of the i don't understand
your comments about tree traversal order
given that we have oh wait a minute so
so there's the question of does
a tree if we've got a tree with three
legs so to speak
and the match i see i see so
in the original that's the great thing
about tree element is it's very clear
on whether it matches so in other words
if you say i want
to match all those nodes that have three
um you know three children so to speak
right i could do that by saying tree
element a blank comma
you know i could just use the pattern
tree element
whoops tree elements blank blank blank
blank if i wanted to
right that would mean all tree nodes
that have so what i'm trying to match
there to be clear
is i want to match the tree element
which means the subtree
right different from um if i wanted to
match
just the payload then what i would do is
i would say
x blank here and i would say arrow x
and then i then i would say cases of
that and then i would just get the
payload
without the subtree see what i'm saying
yes yep yes i think
we have currently the function three
select which is able to act on the
subtrees
and and and get them
depending on various criteria but
not two cases right i think we need this
and we also need to be able to deal with
you know if you had something where you
had a labeled
you know if you had a two arrow blank
et cetera et cetera et cetera here right
where
actually even if i said blank arrow
blank you know
x blank there it's a bizarre case but
you see what i'm saying and that will
work with association matching
okay so
uh
okay so let's go um
let's go down here um
should tree extract support general
expressions
what does that mean so tree extract
only accepts a tree in its first
argument
i would think probably yes that that's a
good idea but i
i'm not i'm not wedded to it i don't
know
okay but i think that's a detail
that will be a courtesy of of accepting
an
expert i don't know i think that's iffy
yeah i think
i agree it's a detail and it but it's
also a tricky detail so that's why
well don't worry about it because i
think that honestly if that expert
you know what i worry about is that
rules tree and so on
and expression tree all those kinds of
things they accept different kinds of
inputs and you'd end up with some
bizarre heuristic the tree extract has
to say oh i've got a thing with rules in
it so i should do this
i think it's a slippery slope and
probably one not worth going down
i think let it be a tree for the time
being if there's a good
courtesy thing to allow it to be without
you having trified it
so be it but that's initially planned
for it just being a tree
right so there are there's only four
functions right now that have a courtesy
of accepting something other than a tree
and they're
natural in those situations so well i
mean things like rules tree obviously it
accepts rules right it doesn't expect
you to be giving it a tree
but like tree insert if you try to
insert two
at a position as a courtesy it creates a
leaf with two in it
i think that's okay yeah i mean i
because we don't really have a way of
same form as in rules tree or a tree
itself
i'm sorry i don't think well whether you
accept rules tree as a courtesy i'm not
certain i'm not certain that's a good
idea
probably it is but i'm not absolutely
certain of it
okay um
before we move on to the next section
there is this nice idea
of three paths containing data so the
idea is that three paths
it's moving through the tree structure
and then at some point you say data so
it moves on
to the payload of that node and then you
can continue inside the payload
okay so that we don't really have that
notion for an association for example
do we have that notion we don't have
for a function we have the notion of
going to position zero which goes into
the head
right which is i i say that that
corresponds
because this is what the default
expression tree
would do is the data would contain a
tree
corresponding to the head yeah i
understand but but if you happen to have
a named
element of the association that is
the tree you know then your toast
right in other words if the if the sub
trees if one of the sub trees was called
the data subtree
you're toast at this point you see what
i'm saying
what no i don't see why is that okay
because
because tree path tells you which
subtree number you're going down
right in this case right this is subtree
one this is sub tree two
right but if one of that if that was a
named
if this was an association of those
sub-trees right
and the key of that first association
with data was data
you would go to the wrong place i see
okay wasn't it we call it key of data
i think it using reusing key might be a
good idea because key is a thing that is
meta
and you know if you name a key key well
you get what you
get key is how you originally designed
tree element
to do this thank you well how about we
go back and look at some of that design
we did
a lot of work on it
okay but there was probably a reason for
that right so
you removed that but did you know why
you were removing it
the key rap oh so no you don't know why
you're removing it so it was a good idea
the intention was to first implement
this using the
tree data structure that has just a list
of children i don't care
it's that's not break the design because
of some implementation detail right now
okay so don't break the other design the
other design was thought about
for exactly this reason well i've i
haven't broken the design i don't think
okay the idea was to accom like be able
to add association
later okay but but this would break that
by
by not allowing that right but i mean
what you're describing is one of the
things i don't know how to do
is some um
um
uh to um
you know in an association how do you
get into the name of the
into the the name of the element
i don't actually know do you understand
what i'm saying if you wanted to do this
exact same operation
you're walking down a list of
associations of associations or whatever
right and you say now i want to go if if
i was doing that in functions
i know it's position zero of the
function is the head
do you get what i'm saying yes i don't
know how you do that with associations
and the fact that we haven't needed that
for such a long time is perhaps
interesting
but the situation here is different
because here we need a variety of
keywords i agree
like children part and sibling yes we do
we do and that that's something
completely new in this
framework yes i agree i agree we need
something which is a
a i mean look it's not completely new we
could imagine
um a uh um
a siblings concept you know this has to
do with okay
things like map are a very depth first
creature
right they just go down they look at an
element they do they they deal with that
element it's very local
right we can imagine a non-local map
which asks for siblings where you go to
a given element
you know you you know whether it's map
or something else but you go to element
235
of a of some expression and you say give
me the siblings of this
of that express of that element so
the only thing we have which is similar
is all so you can do
two three all so here we could have
always a bit like
children so we have two three children
it's like
more or less equivalent to two three all
well
but here we need more more than children
yeah right so i think it needs to be
something which is a symbol
because i don't i think that we're we're
going to end up with um
yeah i mean maybe i missed something but
if
we're talking about all i mean what what
is
i mean aren't the list part specs
siblings
no i think the issue is you are if you
think about map
okay you're at a particular and i'm not
sure whether
okay
um i mean map is at a particular depth
right but the issue is in a tree
yeah yeah yeah i want my second cousin
right right so first identify some
element inside the tree
and then from that one you want to refer
to some
family right so the question is in an
expression
if i have element one two seven of
expression
and i want it second cousins we don't
currently have a way to do that we could
have a way to do that
i mean its second cousins are we go up
two levels on the tree
and then we go back down again except
right
and that's not an operation that we
found terribly useful for expressions we
certainly could have it
i mean it would be perhaps interesting
to implement some wfr function
that's based on the stuff we have in
wolf and alpha for genealogical
relations
although genealogical trees are yet
different because because
at least for you know us higher forms of
life we have two parents so to speak
right but the terminology here in in
trees is still genealogical
mostly i know it is i know it is
it's it's some sort of three of one
opponent
right right um
i mean you know part of what we're
trying to do
you know long ago in the xml world there
were things like xslt and the whole
xpath mechanism and so on
and clearly everything that is clean
there we need to be able to do cleanly
with for example pattern lists in
in the list of you know i want element
one two blank
seven et cetera et cetera et cetera we
need to be able to
and that should be very straightforward
if we if we do that correctly with three
elements
we should be able to match either on the
head tags
or on the subtrees if that makes sense
there should be a way of getting a path
where you say and i think this is what
you're trying to describe here
yeah okay i mean because the xml case is
a
is a um is a case we need to uh
um we have looked at
xpath and we try to imitate all these
family relations which are new
three children okay this is ugly
this is definitely ugly and i think we
should try to avoid it
i don't think that's a good idea
um we can have lists as usual
yeah it's just that i think that we
should have lists i think lists are more
useful i think that that
that way we have interoperability with
expression
you know extraction etc etc
that's true i mean we will run again
into what does it mean
questions as we have in extract but it's
fine
yeah i mean so so here among the pigs
and hippos
which ones have a maximum speed i wonder
if a hippo has a maximum speed more than
five miles an hour
well i guess we get to see here
is that what what's that i'm quite sure
they do
is that right they're very big that must
be a lot of momentum
um okay uh
antelope's better okay so this has many
levels on the tree it both has the
higher level
of all the antelopes and the low-level
specific anti-you know the specific
gazelles and things okay
suppose have a land speed of 30 miles
per hour
okay that could be okay
wow can't i'll run them huh
wow 30 miles an hour
my gosh and there i i thought i was
um i thought i was it was uh uh you know
the greek hippopotamus you know river
horse
i thought they only hang out hung out at
never mind that's not are you going
faster in the water
no that can't be there will be
hydrofoils or something anyway
i don't know uh okay well
one learn something new all right let's
just take a look at a few of these
examples
okay i was mistaken on that last point
i wouldn't think so yes that's the speed
of a
yeah anyway okay so
what the heck is this oh that's drawing
a graph
wow what is that i didn't know you could
do that draw a graph
is that obvious that you can do this um
it's something that geographics can do i
mean brett is now working on a
geograph plot function which you do will
do better
and that's what we will expose but
geographics can do
graphs yes i didn't know that
okay family tree
okay
so here what you're doing is
so i mean right now the entity system um
so the key factor is three so we first
construct this
children function isolates iterates
entity value
and then because it takes some time that
we have the an anagonized
form of the whole result okay fine fine
fine
getting the place of birth of all the
notes
right it's interesting
so one of these is like elizabeth ii or
something is that right
somewhere down here or maybe there was a
break
in the whole story i mean is that this
kings of england type deal right kings
and queens of england
okay so this is an example of more
complicated cases in which you have to
look at the whole family to decide the
question
so so we have a three-fold which is able
to do that
so can you explain this example uh here
right so what this is computing is the
person in the in the family tree who had
who was
youngest when they had their first child
compared to everybody else
and so the fold
like the the analog with the ordinary
fold is
when you're folding the list of children
you're taking a running maximum
to figure out who the oldest child was
but the difference with tree fold
compared to fold is that it has this
fourth argument g that specifies how to
combine the result of folding the
children
with the data in a node and so at that
point
you're comparing the age of the parent
to the age of their oldest child and
throughout the course of the tree you're
finding the person who is youngest
um this is interesting a tree outline
so this is a a another display form for
the tree
xml we were thinking of allowing these
to have a specification of what you want
to start with
so it could start by opening some branch
that you are particularly interested in
i see yeah well why not but i mean also
here
this needs to have some way of being
displayed that isn't i mean it's a
little bit i mean this is
this is certainly a better way to deal
with xml than we've had right now
right so tree outline has optional
arguments for
like wrapper functions if you want to
change what gets displayed
and i've somewhere i have a little toy
of trying to display those as
like actual xml tags
okay this is amusing but we should not
worry about mutability at first
right so we've been designing all the
functions so that
they will never mutate the data
structure and if there's anything
they create a copy right and i mean
there might be a left-hand side where
they do that
um
uh
another thing that we would like to
discuss with you is terminology because
we are confused about
whether the sentence means the subtrees
the
what it means the payloads of the
subtrees things like that all right
listen we have run out of time i'm
supposed to be doing another live stream
about uh
business and innovation um q a
so i i've got to go do that um this
needs more time this
i think you should schedule a two-hour
meeting to go over this stuff we've got
a lot of stuff to go over here
um and and please let's let's not lose
the previous design with tree elements
and so on i think these examples look
highly useful
we just should work them all through and
i'm optimistic that we're going to be
able to do something really good here
uh ethan is suggesting tree node instead
of tree elements
it's a possibility should write that
down it's not a terrible idea
earlier when you mentioned having tree
as the wrapper i thought you were
suggesting
tree as the new name for tree element
well it's possible that's the right
thing
yes um
nice to distinguish subtrees from n
nodes in some way so i like tree node
better
yeah it's internal versus internal or
terminal i should say
right um there's a
point from ethan here on a live stream
tree visualization should be made
sensitive to rendering size
it's a pain to make graphs look good
with appropriate fonts and sizes of
different target scales
yeah that's a hard problem
it's a really hard problem i mean i i've
had that problem a bunch
and things i've done with graphs of late
um i mean this is a you know there's a
lot of
um
uh ethers complaining these trees look
very
uh uh early 2000s yeah yeah
these are not the final design for trees
and yes
even tree even tree form is a bit dated
um and uh
uh yes okay
i have to go um this is really
can we try and get a two-hour block
schedule asap
to go on with this preferably before i
have forgotten everything that happened
in this meeting
okay okay thanks and